[Musique]
les états unis viennent d'élire le
premier président noir de l'histoire du
pays
une page d'histoire qui aura été écrite
par les électeurs américains
quand est arrivé ici il ya eu une mais
cette explosion de joie évidemment on
dit trop souvent là notre métier que les
moments sont historiques aux biens par
la crise financière fait trembler wall
street
l'ombre de choc secoue les marchés
financiers canadiens
les actions financières mondiales ont
perdu près de 500 milliards de dollars
au cours de la dernière année 500
millions c'est d'argent qui
disparaissent oui cet adolescent qui
était membre de l'équipe de basket bancs
de leur école et une enseignante ont été
tués dans un accident de la route
c'est l'ensemble de la communauté de
batteuses qui compte 12000 habitants qui
est secoué par cette journée de est très
pénible
tout d'abord des développements dans
cette intervention policière qui s'est
soldée par la mort d'un jeune homme de
18 ans hier à montréal nord la situation
a dégénéré ce soir sur les lieux du
drame plusieurs feux ont été allumés
on a vu là une famille anéantie
littéralement par le chagrin
les deux commissaires déposent leur
rapport qui contient 37 recommandations
gérard bouchard et charles taylor savent
que leurs commissions suscite bien les
attentes contradictoires
c'est la catastrophe à krabi la finance
l'armée colombienne a mené une opération
d'infiltration et forces armées
révolutionnaires de la colombie pour
réussir à libérer ingrid betancourt qui
étaient détenus par les farc depuis six
ans dans la jungle colombienne
fidel castro va quitter la présidence de
cuba après un règne de 49 ans il a pris
les devants et dans un message qui a été
diffusée ce matin dans l'organe du parti
communiste granma
[Musique]